Now let's look at working with the Odyssey brush debug.
So to get started, before creating the brushes,
sorry to use the E-Post in Iliad,
we need to make sure everything works first
by creating a debug stamp.
We just wanna make sure all of our settings
are set in our project correctly before moving on
because you wanna introduce breakpoints
into this working method because if you get too far in
and then realize something's breaking,
you've gotta go back up the chain.
So let's just first start by creating
an Odyssey brushes folder.
We'll add two more folders,
which is the brush library and the stamps.
And that's where we'll store any custom stamps
from the custom brushes.
So just a note here that the debug stamp
is a temporary brush to ensure that your tablet
is working properly in Unreal Engine.
So what we can do, we can right click
in the Odyssey brush folder to create a texture asset.
So if we can't see this Iliad menu,
it means that the plugin isn't installed.
So just double check, go back to the top of the course here,
make sure that Iliad plugin is there,
restart your editor if need be,
and then you should be able to find this Iliad option
with the texture.
And we can rename this texture T underscore draw pad,
set the width and height to 1920, 1080,
change the color to white.
And then if you double click to open the T underscore draw pad
texture, once you've created it,
that's where we'll be able to test our brush from.
So we can also repeat this step in the brush library,
right click Iliad,
and then we wanna get the Odyssey brush here.
So we can rename the texture first brush,
so you can see a file type like this,
then double click to open it,
and that's where we'll modify those parameters as well.
So the Odyssey brushes are used in the Blueprints Editor
Event Graph to modify the parameters of your brush,
and you will be able to modify, customize,
you know, rename the brush you create at any time,
just like any other U asset,
which is an Unreal asset inside the editor.
So we want to now, in the Event Graph of this basic brush,
we want to right click and type debug stamp,
which you can see the debug stamp there,
and then we can right click event on step,
which you can see here,
and then we just want to connect those two together.
You want to compile and save that blueprint,
and they, if you're unsure what they are,
they're the top two icons at the top left of your editor,
you'll find one compile, one save,
and you just want to make sure that's set up.
So to test the brush,
we can open the T-Basic stamp texture,
just by double clicking it,
select the debug brush in the brush selected tab,
and then we can just draw in the viewport,
and you should be able to see that drawing.
Now, if you're unable to see it,
maybe your Wacom driver's out set up,
so again, you could go back to the top
and enable that plugin that we mentioned,
but essentially you should be able to draw and edit
directly inside of Unreal Engine using these tools.